eine neue Eskalation im Krieg gegen die
Ukraine russlands Präsident Putin
kündigt eine Teilmobilmachung an und
will 300.000 Reservisten einziehen ab
heute das sei ein Akt der Verzweiflung
sagt der Bundeskanzler der Russland vor
der unvollversammlung gestern Abend
blanken Imperialismus vorgeworfen hat
die Ukraine hatte ja zuletzt Gebiete im
Osten zurückerobert und was bedeutet nun
diese Reaktion aus Russland auch für die
Diskussion hier bei uns über die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern Putin macht
mobil wie reagiert der Westen unser
Thema in der phönix-
[Musik]
Phoenix Runde
schönen guten Abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus Berlin ich darf Ihnen
meine Gäste vorstellen ich begrüße Anton
Hofreiter von Bündnis 90 die Grünen er
ist Vorsitzender des europaausschusses
des Bundestags und war ja schon im April
in der Ukraine herzlich willkommen dr
Markus Keim Experte für
Sicherheitspolitik bei der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik und ich begrüße
Professor Johannes Warwick er ist
Politikwissenschaftler der Universität
Halle Wittenberg und herzlich willkommen
Kerstin Münstermann sie ist Leiterin der
parlamentsredaktion der rheinischen
post- und verfolgt natürlich auch hier
die innenpolitische Diskussion über die
Waffenlieferungen Herr Hofreiter Teil
Mobilmachung das hat Präsident Putin
jetzt gestern angekündigt und das hat
viele doch aufgeschreckt 300.000
Soldaten sollen eingezogen werden was
ist denn jetzt die richtige Reaktion
darauf
ich glaube die richtige Reaktion darauf
es sich davon nicht so sehr erschrecken
zu lassen sondern wie silence geht es
mit großer Gelassenheit zu sehen denn
man muss sich bewusst machen dass das
eine militärische Wirkung erst in sechs
Monaten entfaltet und deshalb sollten
wir jetzt schauen die Ukraine noch mal
beschleunigt zu unterstützen sowohl
militärisch als auch humanitär als auch
wirtschaftlich denn ist es Wirkung
entfaltet von da gehen noch sechs Monate
und es kommt jetzt da drauf an dass die
Ukraine gut durch den Winter kommt und
da müssen wir noch mal mehr tun okay die
teilmobil machen ist eine Sache aber
Putin hat auch wirklich gedroht hat auch
indirekt gedroht mit einer nuklearen
Antwort wir hören mal einen Teil seiner
Rede von gestern Abend
Ziel des Westens ist es uns zu schwächen
uns auseinander zu dividieren und am
Ende unser Land zu zerstören sie reden
doch offen darüber dass sie es geschafft
haben die Sowjetunion zu zerschlagen und
jetzt ist Russland an der Reihe Probleme
wenn unsere territoriale Einheit
gefährdet ist wenn Russland und unser
Volk geschützt werden müssen wenden wir
natürlich sämtliche uns zur Verfügung
stehenden Mittel an ich blöffle nicht
Präsident Putin das soll uns heute
morgen nicht gestern Abend das muss eben
korrigieren Herr Keimen sie haben gesagt
mal dass wir was gelernt haben in diesem
Krieg nämlich das Waffen wirken und dass
der Präsident beläuft jetzt sagt er
wieder er läuft nicht wie ernst muss man
nehmen was er da sagt also ich bin
durchaus dafür Politiker ernst zu nehmen
mit dem was sie sagen aber ich fand das
das skurrile in einer skurrilen Rede und
wenn Menschen nicht nur der Politik
sondern auch anderen Orts immer betonen
was sie meinen und sagen Sie nicht
löschen dann stellt sich doch
unwidersprochen der ein gegenteilige
Eindruck ein und wir stellen glaube ich
fest dass wir Mitarbeiter nach sechs
sieben Monaten nicht mehr auf diese
Politik reinfallen sollten die man im
Februar März vielleicht noch ernster
nehmen sollte auch einfach aus
Unwissenheit heraus die Politik der
nuklearn Drohungen mit der wir
nahezu jeden Tag konfrontiert sind von
der russischen Führung und die Verweis
auf die roten Linien die über die der
West überschritten hätte mit
Waffenlieferung bisher sehen wir nichts
andere russische Reaktionen die uns
Angst machen sollten da sehe ich weiter
keine Gefahr aber ich glaube der
entscheidende Punkt ist er versucht
damit Einfluss zu nehmen auf die
politischen Debatten weniger in Russland
weniger in der Ukraine sondern in
westlichen Staaten dass wir uns heute
Abend damit befassen ist ja eine
Illustration dessen was er will dass wir
unsere Sorge artikulieren dass diejenige
ermutigt werden die die Sorge
berechtigterweise oder
unberechtigterweise von der Eskalation
haben und das heißt die die Tatsache der
teilmobil machen also das viel mehr
Soldaten dann in die Ukraine geschickt
werden könnten finden Sie nicht
bedrohlich oder gefährlich
PC finde ich das nicht bedrohlich ist
markiert oder sich glaube es kann uns
nicht überraschen das Präsident Putin
entschlossen ist und ich glaube dann hat
er keinen Zweifel aufkommen lassen in
den letzten Monaten und ich glaube trotz
der Freude die in vielen Hauptstädten
Europas empfunden worden ist in den
letzten zwei bis drei Wochen Optik
Gelände Gewinne der Ukraine durften wir
uns doch nicht Illusion hingeben dass
der Krieg vorbei sein würde und ich
glaube in der vorgehaltener Hand haben
wir doch alle mit einer sehr harten
russischen Reaktion gerechnet und ein
Element dessen sehen wir doch heute der
farbig sie haben gesprochen von der
eskalationsdominanz wir haben gesagt
dass Russland ist immer stärker als die
Ukraine und haben deshalb immer sehr
dafür plädiert dass es zu Verhandlungen
kommen sollte nach dieser Ankündigung
von Putin sehen Sie immer noch eine
Möglichkeit mit ihm zu verhandeln ich
würde sagen es gibt keine andere wir
haben keine andere Option als irgendwann
wieder handeln und dieser Krieg wird
nicht auf dem Schlachtfeld entschieden
sondern irgendwann in politischen
Verhandlungen und die Stimmen Markus
Keim völlig zu diese Rede war es skurril
sie war auch unverschämt sie hat die
Tatsachen vollkommen verdreht aber Angst
ist kein guter Ratgeber in der
Sicherheitspolitik aber Verantwortung
und Sorge schon und es war ja nicht nur
die Ankündigung der Zahl
immobilienmachung sondern in der
Kombination mit der Ankündigung von
Referenten es werden jetzt vier Bezirke
im Norden im Osten und im Süden der
Ukraine als russische Staatsgebiet
erklärt das ist ein Irrweg gar keine
Frage was ist die russische Sicht das
heißt es geht künftig in russischer
Perspektive um russische Staatsgebiet
und das geht schon an die vitalen
selbsterklärten Interessen Russlands und
über dieser Krise schwebt nun mal das
Damoklesschwert einer nuklearen
Eskalation das sollten wir nicht uns in
die Hose vormachen natürlich nicht aber
wir sollten das ernst nehmen und
verantwortlich damit umgehen
verantwortlich umgehen
Prozess es dauert sechs Monate bis diese
Teil mobil machen wird wir müssen
deshalb mehr Waffen liefern sehen Sie
das auch so nein das sehe ich nicht so
ich glaube einen Weg der sich nicht als
erfolgreich erwiesen hat vorzusetzen nur
weil man ihn schon angefangen hat ist
nicht der richtige Weg natürlich müssen
wir solidarisch mit der Ukraine sein und
natürlich müssen wir auch die Ukraine
ertüchtigen sich zu verteidigen aber der
Schlüssel für diesen Krieg und diesen
Konflikt der fast unlösbar geworden ist
aber der Schlüssel dieses unlösbaren
Konfliktes ist nach wie vor dass wir uns
Gedanken darüber machen wie wir ihn
einfrieren können und nicht eskalieren
und wir glauben doch nicht daran dass
die Ukraine in der Lage sein wird die
die den Donbass zurückzuerobern und die
Krim zurückzuobern das heißt wir
brauchen einen politisches ein
politisches Moment um diese Dinge wieder
lösbar zu machen das heißt in
unterschiedlich genau dieses politische
Moment die ganze Zeit und er hat sich
für diesen Weg entschieden er hat erneut
ja aber offensichtlich ist er ja in eine
Bedrängnis geraten hat sich entschieden
und ist eben nicht den Weg von
irgendwelchen Verhandlungen gegangen
auch nicht im Geheimen sondern hat sich
während die UN tagte in New York die
Vollversammlung also die Welt dorthin
blickte entschlossen genau den
gegenteiligen Weg zu gehen ich glaube
die Idee dass man doch eine irgendwie
geartete Friedenslösung findet ist noch
mal nach der Ankündigung dieser
scheinreferenten noch mal
unwahrscheinlicher geworden was würden
Sie denn sagen Frau Münstermann aus
ihrer Beobachtung hier der
innenpolitischen Diskussion jetzt wir
haben in den letzten Wochen immer diese
Diskussion gehabt welche Panzer nur noch
geliefert werden sollen sehen denken sie
dass sich Olaf Scholz in Richtung der
Grünen bewegt nach dieser Ankündigung
von Putin und bereit ist eben auch
Kampfpanzer zu liefern naja wenn man
Urlaub Scholz in New York beobachtet hat
dort ist er gerade bei der
Generalversammlung dann sind zwei Dinge
glaube ich interessant sie haben es auch
beide genannt er hat einen brutalen
Imperialismus Russland vorgeworfen das
war vor der Rede von Putin heute sprach
er so wie der gesamte Westen von einem
Akt der Verzweiflung also es war die
Idee sich dagegen zu stellen überhaupt
dieses narrativ der Furcht nicht
zuzulassen
Putin Schwäche zu attestieren was er
aber nicht gesagt hat war das was Herr
Hofreiter gefordert hat also die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern hat er
überhaupt nicht heute in den Mund
genommen das hätte er tun können wenn er
es gewollt hätte die grüne
Außenministerin ist am Sonntag erst
hinter sich selbst zurückgefallen also
hat einfach das auch nicht mehr so
dezidiert gesagt wie sie es vorher
gefordert hatte nach einem Gespräch mit
dem Kanzler und ich glaube am Ende wird
sich an dieser vorsichtigen Position
nichts ändern im Gegenteil Putin leidet
wir hören mal rein in das was
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz heute in New
York gesagt hat am Rande der UNO
Vollversammlung seine Rede war ja
gestern Abend und dann als Reaktion auf
die Rede von Putin Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz
die jüngsten Entscheidungen der
russischen Regierung sind ein Akt der
Verzweiflung Russland kann diesen
verbrecherischen Krieg nicht gewinnen
und mit den jüngsten Entscheidungen
macht Putin macht Russland das alles nur
noch viel schlimmer er hat von Anfang an
die Situation komplett unterschätzt den
Widerstand und den Widerstands Willen
der ukraineren Ukraine aber auch die
Geschlossenheit und Entschlossenheit der
Freunde der Ukraine die jetzt
angekündigten scheinreferenten werden
niemals akzeptiert werden natürlich
nicht vom ukrainischen Volk aber auch
nicht von der Weltgemeinschaft und
können deshalb keine Rechtfertigung
dafür bieten was Russland tatsächlich
vorhat nämlich mit Gewalt das Land des
Nachbarn zu erobern oder Teile des
Territoriums davon das wird niemals
akzeptiert werden können in der Welt in
der wir leben muss das Recht über die
gewaltigen und kann nicht die Gewalt
stärker sein als das Recht Herr
Hofreiter was hätten sie sich da
gewünscht als Reaktion das alles ist
richtig man muss halt auch die
Konsequenzen daraus folgen lassen und
von dem was vorher gerade angesprochen
ist sind halt mehrere Dinge falsch nicht
die Waffenlieferungen haben sogar besser
gewirkt als wir es erhofft haben der
Ukraine ist es gelungen das ganze
torritorium um Kiew zurück zu erobern es
ist ja sogar gelungen große Gebiete im
Osten zu befreien und es ist eher
gelungen die Vorstöße im Donez und im
Süden zu stoppen und sie hat damit dafür
gesagt dass ganz viele Menschen am
geschützt worden sind vor der russischen
Aggression und es hat nur funktioniert
dank der westlichen Waffenlieferung und
wenn wir noch schneller und mehr
geliefert hätten dann wäre das sogar
noch erfolgreicher gewesen und der
Grundfehler bei der Annahme ist man muss
das mit Verhandlungen lösen ist das zu
Verhandlungen kann einfach zwei dazu das
muss man halt einfach immer akzeptieren
und der russische Präsident Putin hat
noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht in seiner
Rede dass er jetzt nicht bereit ist zu
verhandeln zumindest nicht vernünftig
und wie bringt man kommt dazu der nicht
verhandeln will und gleichzeitig sehr
skrupellos ist man sagt dafür dass die
Kosten des nicht Verhandelns für ihn
immer höher werden und diese Kosten des
nicht Verhandelns werden dadurch für ihn
immer höher indem wir bei den Sanktionen
hart bleiben wo es geht sie noch
ausweiten und die Verteidigungsfähigkeit
der Ukraine erhöhen dass am Ende erkennt
er kann diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen und
es tun wir indem wir die Ukraine
unterstützen und da haben wir viel getan
schon als Bundesrepublik aber ich würde
mir wünschen dass wir noch mehr tun was
musst du aus ihrer Sicht die
Bundesrepublik tun um die Ukraine zu
stärken also da ist eine Menge passiert
und da will ich ist es auch nicht an mir
zu kritisieren was ich als eine
Lehrstelle empfinde ist was etwas
anderes
militärisches handeln wir sind nicht
Kriegsparteien das ist mir völlig klar
aber militärisches handeln muss immer
eine politische Zweck dienen sonst ist
bedeutungslos und da finde ich da ist
doch die
Bundesregierung sehr schweigsam was sie
denn eigentlich als politisch
langfristiges Ziel erreichen will und
ich glaube das wird
nicht mehr lange durchzuhalten sein weil
wir haben das war eure Katze
angesprochen wir sind demnächst mit
einer Situation konfrontiert wo wir
völkerrechtlich sagen der Don BOS gehört
so Ukraine die Krim gehört zu Ukraine
und dennoch steht die Frage im Raum sind
wir bereit die Ukraine bei einem Waffen
Gang in den donvas hinein in die
kriminalen politisch zu unterstützen und
damit sozusagen
fällt auf dass es wenig Auskünfte
darüber gibt wie weit denn diese
Unterstützung dort wohnungsrepublik für
die Ukraine reichen würde da hat man
sich immer durchgerettet mit die Ukraine
darf nicht verlieren Russland darf nicht
gewinnen ja das ist wohlfeil aber was
heißt das konkret und ein zweites
Beispiel die Außenministerin als im
April gesagt dass sie
Sicherheitsgarantie für die Ukraine
abgeben wurde der Kanzler zum G7 Tropfen
wiederholt aber was das konkret heißen
würde was denn die Bundesregierung zu
tun bereit wäre alleine oder im
verbundenen anderen auch das ist eine
Lehrstelle und ich glaube das ist nicht
mehr lange auszuhalten also es fehlt
sozusagen die klare Idee wohin man will
die politische Dimension des
militärischen Handels fehlt
dazu sagen was ich vorher schon gesagt
habe man muss die Ukraine so
unterstützen dass man Russland zu
ernsthaften Verhandlungen
und zwar zu Verhandlungen die für beide
Seiten glaubwürdig sind zwingen und des
Weiteren bei den Sicherheitsgarantien
sehe ich nur zwei Möglichkeiten entweder
kommt man am Ende zu dem Ergebnis die
Ukraine werden oder man startet sie so
sehr mit Waffen aus dass immer klar ist
dass sie in der Lage ist einen
neuerlichen Angriffsversuch von Russland
im Keim zu ersticken es sind die
einzigen beiden Möglichkeiten es gab das
Budapester manchmal random da waren
Großbritannien die USA und absurderweise
Russland die garantiemächte dafür dass
die Ukraine alle ihre Atombomben
hergegeben hat und deshalb wird man
diese
Sicherheitsgarantien deutlich robuster
ausstatten müssen und wenn sich die NATO
ist muss man sie entsprechend mit
ausreichend Waffen hinterlegen ich
glaube die die verhandlungsoptionen sind
ja eigentlich klar und die sind alle
schlecht überhaupt keine Frage und das
ist nichts was ich mir wünsche und im
übrigen auch nichts was ich der Ukraine
von hier raten würde aber wenn man sich
das mal nüchtern anschaut und sich auf
diese schreckliche Rede von Putin heute
anhört und auch die von Scheu GU dann
wird doch klar dass offenkundig das
Maximalziel was die Russen am Anfang
hatten nämlich die Ukraine als Souverän
Staat zu vernichten nicht mehr so in den
öffentlichen in die Öffentlichkeit
getragen wird das heißt dass ein
Minimalziel ist jetzt der Donbass und
der Teile der Südukraine also zapporita
und Cherson und das ist nicht schön
natürlich das wäre aber da muss die
Ukraine
wir müssen hier am Tisch nicht die
Ukraine aufteilen aber das ist doch die
einzig realpolitisch denkbare Richtung
in der Natur auch irgendwann ja in der
man überhaupt handeln kann und möchte
nicht habe ich mir das wünsche es sind
jetzt noch mal erklärtermaßen vital
Interessen der Russen für die Sie bereit
sind nicht nur zu eskalieren sondern
vielleicht sogar nuklear zu eskalieren
und wir müssen es überlegen wollen wir
was dagegen halten dann ranten wir am
Ende im Krieg mit Russland oder
versuchen wir einen Modus wie wenn die
zu schaffen der nicht den Konflikt löst
und der auch nicht bedeutet dass wir das
Anerkennen wir haben die Annexion der
baltischen Staaten nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg auch nicht anerkannt aber das
ist das ist Argumentation wir müssen das
in diesem Konflikt in der Schwebe halten
und die die als Alternativszenario zu in
der schwebehalten ist eine Eskalation
und wenn man das abwägt dann kann man
als nüchterne Realpolitiker denke ich
nur zu dem Ergebnis kommen dass eine ein
Einfrieren die bessere Option ist als in
einem Krieg mit Russland zu landen
dass sie dem zugeben muss dass sie diese
Zugeständnisse machen muss ja das würde
ich raten und sie ist auch von uns
abhängig das heißt am Ende hat sie gar
keine andere Wahl als sozusagen darauf
auch einzugehen strategischen
Vorstellungen der Westen hat weil sie
alleine überhaupt keine Chance hätte
weiter zu existieren aber das ist doch
genau das Muster des die ganze Zeit
erzählt wird am Anfang hieß es man
braucht nicht zu und zur Unterstützung
der Ukraine weil sie nach drei Tagen
nach drei Tagen eh verloren hat dann
hieß es Waffenlieferungen bringen nichts
wir brauchen die gar nicht machen und
die Ukraine soll sozusagen möglichst
schnell einen diktatfrieden zustimmen
jetzt ist bewiesen die Ukraine hat die
Region um Kiew zurückerobert sie hat die
Region und Kaki zurückerort und jetzt
sozusagen wird wieder die Geschichte
sozusagen die im Grunde Russland erzählt
hier mit trauriger Mine als Realpolitik
präsentiert und wieder ist diese
Geschichte falsch nämlich wenn man die
Sanktionen aufrecht erhalten und wenn
wir entsprechend auch dafür sorgen dass
hier bei uns im Westen entsprechend mit
sozialpolitischen Maßnahmen dafür
Gesagte dass auch ärmere Menschen die
Sanktionen mittragen können und wir die
Ukraine weiter unterstützen dann werden
wir sehen dass Ukraine im Süden weiter
vorrückt dann werden wir sehen dass sie
im Osten weiter vorrückt und Putin wird
weiter Drohungen ausstoßen aber er wird
diese Drohungen ausstoßen nicht weil er
sie umsetzen will das sagen Ihnen alle
Experten die sich da intensiver
beschäftigen wir sagen Ihnen auch die
Chinesen die da ein hohes Interesse drin
haben sondern er wird weiter Drohungen
ausstoßen einfach deshalb damit es hier
bei uns im Westen entsprechend
wiederholt wird das ist nichts anderes
als wie einwirken und zu hoffen dass wir
sozusagen zu schwach sind zu unüberlegt
sind nicht zu realpolitisch sondern zu
kopflos um auf seine Propaganda
reinzufallen man merkt an dieser rede
ich fand die überhaupt nicht wir sondern
einen gut ausgebildeten
kgb-propagandisten der diese Rede
gehalten hat genau für solche Runden wie
hier um genau solche Wortmeldungen wie
von ihnen zu erzeugen und
das ist denn das kann ich so nicht
stehen lassen
genau das werden Sie sagen keine
politische Strategie sie setzen ein
dinosaurierlieferung das hat bisher
Erfolge gebracht gar keine Frage aber
das wird nicht neu erklären sie noch
gesagt das ist keine Erfolge ein Land
voll Pump mit Waffen dann ist natürlich
hat das Erfolge ist doch gar keine Frage
aber es wird nicht dazu führen dass die
Ukraine zu einem vertretbaren Preis mit
unserer Unterstützung den Don Bass
zurückerobert und die Krim zurückerobert
so das ist ein Faktum das heißt wir
brauchen ja das ist schwierig die
Ukraine wollte keine Waffen sie wollte
einfach in Ruhe weiterleben und in ihren
Grenzen weiterleben
dass wir diesen Konflikt nicht
eskalieren und wir brauchen uns hier
nicht gegenseitig Vorwürfe machen
sondern lassen uns auch nüchtern darüber
reden wie man diesen Konflikt befrieden
kann und wir reden natürlich wie sie auf
die Propaganda Situation
Funktion und ich verlange von allen die
sich damit beschäftigen Seriosität und
sozusagen nicht nur mit heißem Herzen
diese Dinge zu sehen sondern mit kühlen
Blick und da unterscheiden wir uns eben
genau kühlen Blick sorgen wir dafür dass
wir Putin in Verhandlungen zwingen und
fallen nicht auf seine Propaganda rein
die noch dazu sehr sehr vorhersehbar war
und deswegen ist es schon fast lustig
sozusagen wie sie genau sozusagen sich
dem Drehbuch entsprechenden
sie ja nicht dazu die Position zu
einziehen
glaube ich jetzt klar geworden ich würde
gerne noch mal darauf gucken was daraus
folgt was auch für die Politik hier
folgt Frau Münstermann es wird einen
Antrag im Bundestag geben von der CDU
die fordert eben die bestimmte
Kampfpanzer zu liefern das was
Bundeskanzler Scholz bisher nicht tun
will welches Zeichen ist das und wohin
bewegt sich sozusagen die Diskussion
denken Sie das stolz dann doch in diese
Richtung einnimmt ja da ist der
Unionsfraktion Friedrich Merz
CDU-Vorsitzender sehr entschieden er
sagt wir haben im April als Bundestag
mit großer Mehrheit ein Antrag
verabschiedet schwere Waffen zu liefern
das sei aus seiner Sicht bislang so
nicht Erfolg also setzt hier die
Opposition die Regierung unter Druck das
ist auch ihr gutes Recht und die
Diskussion ist spannend weil man
natürlich
wenn man sie hört sie in dem Fall eher
bei der Opposition wehnt als in Teilen
der Regierung denn Scholz und die SPD
ist da sehr sehr vorsichtig sehr
zurückhaltend und ich glaube wie gesagt
nicht dass die Eskalation die wir jetzt
sehen Scholz zu einer anderen
Haltung bringt ich glaube eher dass er
etwas aufnimmt nämlich eine gewisse
vorsichtige sowieso schon hat also
getroffener Hund bellt hat heute mal
jemand im Hintergrund gesagt und
diese Idee einer gewissen Vorsicht die
wird Scholz meines Erachtens nicht
aufgeben mit heute wie erklären Sie sich
diese Vorsicht ja
viel spekuliert man hört von angeblichen
irgendwelchen Informationen die er hat
und dir zurückhält ich glaube das nicht
glaube sie haben einen wichtigen Punkt
angesprochen der für so seine Vorsicht
auch steht es geht ihm glaube ich drum
möglichst viel Bevölkerung mitzunehmen
und es fängt ja an doch etwas zu
erodieren also das Wort der
Kriegsmüdigkeit jetzt reden wir gerade
wieder drüber aber das die Bevölkerung
an Gesichts der Erschwernisse im Winter
schon fragt denken wir an die eigene
Situation quasi einige
Energieversorgungen sind wir doch auch
gefährdet und diese Reden die kann man
politisch analysieren und kann sagen
Putin hat vielleicht doch nicht das so
das ist ein Zeichen der Schwäche ich
glaube dass es vielen Menschen erstmal
anders geht die sind heute Morgen nicht
gut aufgewacht und meines Erachtens
versucht Olaf Scholz dass etwas
abzuholen hey kein Beat bedrohlich ist
die Situation dann wenn man das hört
also mit der nuklearen Drohung verstehen
Sie dass sich vielen Menschen jetzt
Sorgen machen dass es eben so verliert
wie gefährlich oder können Sie Teile der
Ängste nehmen
ich bin kein ich bin kein Seelsorger
aber
ich kann das schon durchaus verstehen
also ich meine wir sind alle hier in der
Berliner Blase wir verfolgen Politik
seit langem Jahren beschäftigungs-
und gehen sehen sind in dem im
wohlverstanden sind etwas abgebrühter
vielleicht aber vielleicht für viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die das nicht
täglich verfolgen und die Hörenden
russischen Präsidenten jetzt sagt out of
the Tisch und sagt und dann wird der
Westen ein Preis dafür zahlen und ich
Blöcke nicht und glaubte und dann fällt
auch noch das Wort nuklear dann haben
wir eine Melange die in vielen
Haushalten für Unruh sorgt und die
zweite Facette haben sie gerade völlig
zu Recht angesprochen selbst wir selbst
wenn das nicht verfolgt sieht seine
Stromrechnung oder Ihre Stromrechnung in
den nächsten Tagen Wochen kommen und
dann sehe ich auch tatsächlich wenn wir
mal den nächsten Schritt denken und
sagen wollen wir die Sanktion weiter
zuspitzen weiter verschärft eine etwas
andere Diskussion als wir die im April
gehabt haben
gerne in der Bundesrepublik selber aber
auch im europäischen Kontext wo er auch
es war anstehen Italien am Sonntag eine
der Anführungsstrichen Wackelkandidat
was die Sanktion betrifft da könnte ich
mal mit einer neuen Regierung auch eine
ganz andere Gemengelage vorstellen im
europäischen Kontext
Herr Hofreiter werden sie denn diesem
Antrag zustimmen der cdu/cs
Abgeordneter keine positionsanträgen zu
sich sollte ein Antrag von der anderen
Seite wünschen so ist unser System nicht
und außerdem ist ja manches irreführend
nicht wir liefern ja wirklich sehr sehr
schwere Waffen also wir liefern die
Panzerhaubitze 2000 das ist eine der
schwersten Waffen die wir überhaupt
haben wir haben den Gepard Panzer
geliefert das ist der
durchschlagskräftigste Panzer den wir
überhaupt haben dann hat die Bundeswehr
nicht ausgemustert war er alt war
sondern bei ihr zu teuer war also das
ist also das Beste vom Besten deswegen
ist diese Debatte ja auch so seltsam
warum wir nicht einfach mehr tun was wir
sonst noch haben um den sich schneller
zu beenden aber wie gesagt ich glaube
was halt unsere Aufgabe ist den Leuten
deutlich zu machen das was Putin macht
ist es wirklich ein Zeichen von Schwäche
und des Weiteren ist unsere Aufgabe
dafür zu sorgen
dass die Last der Sanktionen und da
müssen wir auch noch besser werden wenn
man sich die Gaspreise und die
Strompreise an die Last den Leuten
wegzunehmen
wir haben auch viele haben bis zum 24
Februar nicht gedacht dass er dort
einmarschiert dann ist er aber
einmarschiert also wie können sie sich
da so sicher sein dass er nicht
weitergeht auf der einen Seite sozusagen
hat er davor immer verkündet dass sie
die Ukraine erobern will
und es hat er dann gemacht da wollten
wir nicht glauben was er gesagt hat
sozusagen und er hat es dann am Ende
gemacht und hier in dem Fall gibt es
ganz technische Gründe also wir wissen
zum Beispiel dass die Atomwaffen sind
militärischen keinster Form scharf
gemacht auch letztendlich die
Zusammenarbeit mit den Amerikanern nach
allem was wir wissen funktioniert da
immer noch also es aus den Worten folgt
bis jetzt überhaupt nichts und des
Weiteren kommt dazu dass der Preis hat
für Russland fast unendlich wäre wenn
ich für China ist auch vollkommen klar
dass sie nie und nimmer akzeptieren
würden das Russland eine taktische
Atombombe und darüber reden wir ja eine
taktische Atombombe in der Ukraine
einsetzt also das ist ja das was
überhaupt nur befürchtet wird und das
ist für die Chinesen vollkommen klar und
wenn er auch noch die Chinesen als so
halb Bündnispartner verliert dann ist er
in so großen Schwierigkeiten deswegen
man muss da vorsichtig sein man muss da
vernünftig sein man muss das Abwägen
aber bei allen Abwägungen auch gerade
wenn man international unterwegs ist
sind die Fachleute dann doch und zwar in
allen Ländern wo ich sie gesprochen habe
und wie gesagt bis China der Meinung das
ist ganz sicher
also ich behaupte jetzt überhaupt nicht
dass übermorgen einen Einsatz seiner
taktischen Nuklearwaffe ansteht und dass
das unvermeidlich ist das nicht mal ein
Argument aber mein Argument ist das
Russland über die eskalationsdominanz
verfügt das ist am oberen Ende nuklear
das ist eher unwahrscheinlich Gewicht zu
aber auch da drunter gibt es viele
Optionen die für die Ukraine schlecht
sind zum Beispiel härtere Angriffe auf
cyber-infrastruktur zum Beispiel härtere
Angriffe auf sogenannte kritische
Infrastruktur also
energieversorgungswerke vieles andere
Russland kann also noch eskalieren und
wenn der rufreiter sagt Putin handelt
aus Schwäche dann stimme ich dem
ausdrücklich zu aber ein sozusagen
Diktator der in die Enge getrieben ist
aus Schwäche ist nicht ungefährlicher
das heißt wir sollten einfach nüchtern
uns anschauen was da vor sich geht und
ich bin mit meinen Warnungen ja nun
wirklich nicht alleine Joe Biden hat
öffentlich gesagt dass sein oberstes
Ziel ist ein dritten Weltkrieg zu
vermeiden Schol nimmt dem zu die
amerikanischen Geheimdienste war eine
New York Times und anderswo zu lesen
sind so besorgt wie nie das heißt der
Krieg kommt jetzt in eine Phase die
wirklich gefährlich wird und wir sollten
in dieser Phase mit Besonnenheit
reagieren und das heißt nicht dass wir
jetzt die weiße Fahne hissen sollen und
sagen Putin bekommt alles was er will
aber das heißt
wir diesen Konflikt richtig lesen müssen
und da wenn ich ihn lese dann komme ich
zu dem Ergebnis dass wir militärisch
nicht bereit sind für die Ukraine in den
Krieg zu ziehen die
waffenlieferungsstrategie ist eine
ersatzstrategie gewissermaßen die aber
an Grenzen stößt weil die politische
Linie machen hat das gut beschrieben
nicht klar ist wir müssen über die
politischen Ziele reden und dann kann
man möglicherweise auch darüber reden
wie man die Ukraine unterstützen muss
wäre dann was ist denn ihre Meinung nach
geht es um Besonnenheit und geht es
darum dass wie kann Deutschland richtig
reagieren auch weil viele ja von
Deutschland eine stärkere Führungsrolle
erw
ja wer will gegen Besonnenheit sein das
ist jetzt man das um was heißt das denn
konkret was ist jetzt die richtige
besonnene Entscheidung die nicht noch
weiter eskaliert
wenn es da mal eine einfache Antwort
gebe also ich kann mit dem Kurs der
Bundesregierung ja was anfangen ich
würde gerne auch noch einen Einwand
aufgreifen die wir noch gar nicht
versprochen haben das Argument ist
allein Gangs oder das ausbleibende
alleine ist das ist auch Argument das
mir einleuchtet sagen dass die
Bundesregierung sich in der
Konfrontation mit Russland die
Deutschland eingegangen ist nicht sich
nicht alleine exponieren will das sollte
mir völlig anders man muss ja nicht mehr
Gegnerschaft mir Feindschaft mehr
Reaktion auf sich ziehen als das
sogenannte
Punkt weiter ja gleichermaßen wir rot im
letzten Teil wie ich finde sehr guten
Vorschlag gemacht und dann wird ein
Schuh draus wenn man sagt mit der was
heißt eigentlich führungsmarkt
führungsmarkt heißt ja nicht alleine
handeln für uns macht heißt Koalition
zusammenzubringen ihr Vorschlag wenn ich
ihn richtig verstanden habe war ja im
europäischen Verbund die Zahl hat jetzt
mal außen vor wie viele lebh Panzer es
gibt aber im europäischen Verbund das zu
organisieren und das wäre finde ich eine
Initiative mit Augen Spaß mit
Verantwortung der zu organisieren und es
hätte finde ich noch einen angenehmen
Nebeneffekt dass man den USA mal
signalisieren könnte dass Europa stärker
Verantwortung für die eigene Sicherheit
auf dem eigenen Kontinent trägt und das
Deutschland hat ja gesagt Deutschland
soll eine neue Führungsrolle da
übernehmen nichts gegen die
verteilungsminister mehr ist nicht ganz
klar ob sie durchdacht hat was sie damit
meint und künftige Generationen eher
gemeint ist für den aktuellen Konflikt
also das gelesen ja also hat sie sich da
vertan vor galoppiert oder
naja es war eine Grundsatzrede die sie
gehalten hat und ich finde sie hat für
eine SPD-Politikerin schon
interessante Sachen gesagt also
führungsnationen Waffenverkäufe das sind
alles Themen die für die Partei
eigentlich bis dato nicht machbar waren
da hat sie sozusagen etwas aufgegriffen
sie hat ja auch bei dieser Rede vor zwei
Wochen glaube ich erneute
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
verkündet nachdem der Kanzler kurz
vorher gesagt hat nee also es kommt
nichts mehr das ist ja auch immer so ein
bisschen so ein Domino also wir sagen
immer wir machen nichts und dann machen
wir aber doch ganz viel die Liste der
deutschen Lieferung ist sehr sehr lang
aber es geht eben um diese Kampfpanzer
und da wird niemand Scholz davon
abbringen glaube ich in der nächsten
Zeit sich sozusagen aus dem Schatten dem
vermeintlichen von dem US-Präsidenten
Joe Biden zu lösen den er immer immer
wieder auch zitiert
die Rede und ich bin absolut für
Besonnenheit und deswegen wie gesagt
sollten wir zum Beispiel auf diese Rede
von Putin eben nicht so ein ängstlich
und eingeschichtet reagieren sondern
vollkommen besonnen und nüchtern uns
anschauen was in den vergangenen Monaten
funktioniert hat Putin hat gedroht wir
haben die Ukraine Stärke unterstützt
ukrainte konnte den Vormarsch aufhalten
wir haben die Ukraine noch stärker
unterstützt die Ukraine konnte sogar
Gelände zurückgewinnen und genauso
besonnen nicht ängstlich sollten wir
darauf reagieren und deshalb der
Vorschlag es gibt 13 Länder die Leopard
2 Panzer in Europa und die sind 13
Länder sollten wir organisieren und das
mit dem Alleingang teile ich absolut wir
wissen bloß dass von diesen 13 Ländern
eine ganze Reihe von Ländern gerne
Leopard 2 Panzer an die Ukraine liefern
würden aber wir es ihnen informell immer
wieder untersagen und die würden sich
einfach sehr wünschen dass wir so ein
Bündnis schmieden und dann gemeinsam das
zeigen und auch die Amerikaner erwarten
das von uns nämlich wenn du mit denen
unter der Hand sprichst dann sagen die
das ist ein Krieg in Europa kümmert euch
mal ein bisschen mehr darum wir haben so
viele Haubitzen wir haben so viele
Raketen ja vergeliefert jetzt könntet
ihr doch mal entsorgernbereich sozusagen
nicht alleine aber im Bündnis
zusammenarbeiten das ist eigentlich die
Erwartungshaltung die aus Amerika und
signalisierte natürlich nicht und
diplomatisch natürlich nicht
konfrontativ weil so ist die Regierung
bald nicht aber wenn sie sich den Tweet
der us-botschafterin anschauen also das
ist für eine Diplomatin schon ziemlich
einsam die Entscheidung über die Art der
Hilfen die bei jedem Land selbst aber
sie erwartet eigentlich dass man da eben
eine stärkere Führungsrolle hat Herr
farbig wäre denn das was wäre denn
dagegen zu sagen wenn man sagt wenn sich
so viele Länder zusammentun wenn es kein
Alleingang ist und sich die ihre Kräfte
bündeln und auch ganz klar dann sagen
jetzt liefern wir die Waffen die die
Ukraine braucht was hätten sie denn da
geben die Frage ist wofür braucht die
Ukraine diese Waffen das haben wir
gerade diskutiert solange das politische
Ziel nicht glasklar ist glaube ich ist
das keine richtige Strategie ja aber das
die amerikanische Perspektive ist ja
bisher so dass man nichts tut was oder
die rote Linie gewissermaßen war dass
die Ukraine nicht in russische
Staatsgebiet gewissermaßen vorrücken
kann einschließlich Krim wobei das kein
russisches Staatsgebiet ist sondern
völkerrechtlich ukrainisches Territorium
das heißt die Amerikaner in der New York
Times war das so beschrieben dass man
wenn man so viel Waffen und so harte
Waffen vor sechs Monaten geliefert hätte
wie man heute liefert dann wäre es schon
eine richtige Kriegserklärung in
Russland gewesen und man macht das jetzt
wie Bowling the frogs sozusagen
eskaliert immer ein Stück weiter und die
Frage ist wo ist die Grenze wo Russland
wirklich in Schwierigkeiten kommt und
wenn es wirklich in Schwierigkeiten
kommt wie reagiert dann Russland und die
Amerikaner haben das bisher relativ klug
austariert weil glaube ich Joe Biden
einen Blick dafür hat dass er dieses
Ziel einer Konfrontation mit Russland
umfasst jeden Preis vermeiden will und
die Frage ist können wir das mit dieser
Strategie weiter vermeiden oder müssen
wir nicht ein politisches Ziel
definieren für die für das es sich dann
auch lohnt die Ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen das wäre mein Ansatz ich
würde bei sozusagen sprach ist einfach
sehr verräterisch sie haben gerade
gesagt der Westen eskaliert immer weiter
und der Westen eskaliert nicht sondern
Russland ist skaliert aber
ist verräterisch und das sieht man
einfach sozusagen
ich zitiere sie selbst und sie nennen es
dann eine Unterstellung ich zitiere sie
selbst dass sie davon gesprochen haben
der Westen eskaliert immer stufenweise
und deshalb und deshalb sozusagen
wirklich einfach mal sagen sie sind
nicht besonnen sondern sie lassen sich
vom Putin einschüchtern und fallen auf
seine Propaganda rein und ich glaube das
dürfen wir als freie Gesellschaften
nicht tun wir müssen eben genau besonnen
vernünftig klug und abgewogen reagieren
und wir müssen auch die politische
Strategie noch mal klarer kommunizieren
deswegen betone ich immer wieder wir
müssen Russland zur Verhandlungen
zwingen wir unterstützen die Ukraine so
stark dass Russland zu ernsthaften
Verhandlungen bereit ist und es ist
bisher Russland noch nicht weil es den
Eindruck hat der Preis ist nicht hoch
genug denn es zahlt Putin hat selbst
genug oft genug gesagt ich habe Zeit und
deshalb müssen wir das tun
wir einfach alle noch nicht was was
passiert wie das in Russland selber
wahrgenommen wird denn ehrlich gesagt
von der spezialoperation das Wort Krieg
durfte schon bei Gefängnisstrafen nicht
sagen zu einer Teilmobilmachung von
300.000 Menschen die eine sagen wir mal
einen Anstieg von oneway Tickets heute
ausgelöst hat Menschen wollen raus aus
Russland es gab vorhin Bilder von der
finnischen Grenze Finish russischen
Grenze weil das die einzige ist wo man
mit einem schengenwieser noch rüberkommt
ich frage mich schon was also eigentlich
hat Putin sich selber der Lüge überführt
heute Morgen und hat auf einmal
zugegeben dass es eben offensichtlich
ihm doch um mehr es um eine militärische
sonderoperation geht und was das mit dem
mit Russland macht mit den Russen macht
was das auch mit der Situation im Land
macht das glaube ich kann von uns keine
es gab 200 Festnahmen bis jetzt und es
gibt gab viele Proteste auch keinem
sehen sie da eine Chance eine
Möglichkeit dass zu sagen jetzt jetzt
natürlich wo klar ist da ist ein Krieg
und wo Menschen noch mal mehr spüren
dass sie ihre Väter Söhne Männer dorthin
schicken müssen das ist doch mehr
Protest im gibt der etwas bewirken kann
da möchte ich mir keine Otter darüber
erlauben da fehlt mir auch wirklich die
Russland Expertise aber ich finde von
münstermanns Argumenten gewichtiges oder
ihre Betrachtung gewichtiger ist weil du
Präsident Putin musste ja heute morgen
eine sehr feine Linie treffen auf der
einen Seite eskalieren also quantitativ
eskalieren gleichzeitig suggerieren es
hat sich nichts geändert und diese
Quadratur des Kreises da kann man sagen
die ist vielleicht bei 300.000 noch
aufgegangen aber wenn es 500.000 sind
heute kursiert ja die Zahlen wir
behalten uns vor 25 Millionen die Zahl
dieser genannt worden von Reservisten zu
ziehen das hätte fundamentale Auswirkung
für die für die für die
aushilfegesellschaft und um das Wort was
uns am Anfang bewegt hat hier nochmal zu
verwenden dann könnte der blöd wirklich
auffliegen mit ungeahnten Folgewirkungen
für russische Politik und ich würde das
eben auch weniger als militärisches
Argument sondern als politisches
Argument werden wollen sagen das
beschränkt ihn auch in seiner
eskalationsfähigkeit also militärisch
die völlig unstr aber ich glaube er wird
sich politisch sehr gut überlegen wie
weit er militärisch geht mit
generalmobil machen und anderes mehr
weil das ist doch deutlich geworden er
hat den diesen Krieg so stark mit seiner
Person verknüpft ist ist sein Krieg das
alles was damit an Folgewirkungen für
die russische Gesellschaft passiert ihm
persönlich angerechnet wird und das
würde seine innenpolitische Legitimation
weiter unterminieren Herr Hofreiter wie
sollten wir mit dieser Türen umgehen aus
Russland
sofort asylambieten denn wir sollten
auch noch mal stärker mit der
Zivilgesellschaft zusammenarbeiten denn
wir sollten versuchen die immer
schwächeren Teile der russischen
Gesellschaft die woanders ist so gut zu
unterstützen wie wir können
gibt es denn da überhaupt die
Möglichkeit der Unterstützung zur Zeit
ja ich glaube schon wie zum Beispiel
dieser turn asylanbieten Menschen die
rausholen entsprechend auch
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten anbieten deshalb
ich kann absolut verstehen wenn Länder
im Baltikum russischen Touristen kein
Visum mehr anbieten können angesichts
der Situation aber wir sollten alle
Menschen die raus wollen aus dem System
Putin unterstützen und ich glaube da
gibt es noch einige Möglichkeiten und
das sollten wir tun
was denken Sie wie lange sich dieser
Krieg noch hinziehen wird wenn wir jetzt
sie haben gesagt Teil mobil machen wird
dann erst in sechs Monaten letztendlich
wirklich greifen diese Zeit sollte man
nutzen Herr Farwick was würden auf was
stellen sie sich da ein was denken Sie
wie lange dieser Krieg noch da ich habe
keine Glaskugel ich habe gelernt dass
dieser Krieg Überraschungen bereithält
das ist keine neue erkenntnisklausewitz
hat gesagt ein Großteil eines Krieges
vollzieht sich im Nebel und in der
Ungewissheit das ist auch hier so ich
fürchte nur dass das noch eine Weile
dauern wird und dass das eher in einen
abnutzungskrieg endet wo keiner was raus
gewinnen kann die Durchhaltefähigkeit im
Westen wird schwächer wenn wir merken
wie abhängig wir sind wenn hier
sozusagen soziale Verwerfungen entstehen
sprechen Sie mal mit Bankern den steht
die Panik im Gesicht geschrieben
sozusagen das heißt die Rückendeckung
glaube ich wird nicht größer über den
Winter und dann ist die Frage was
passiert ob der Druck für politische
Lösung steigt oder ob dann im Frühjahr
das weitergeht und das in einen
nimmerwährenden abnutzungskrieg
gewissermaßen übergeht der Jahre dauern
kann und das wäre das schlechteste
Szenario ich bin dafür dass wir ständig
neue Anläufe machen für politische
Lösungen ich habe auch kein Masterplan
natürlich aber wir müssen mehr Energie
und auch mehr Fantasie in politische
Lösungen legen ja Frau Münstermann was
denken sie wie oder wie nehmen sie es
wahr wie sich die Politik einstellt auch
die Bundesregierung auf welchen
Zeithorizont
ich glaube man stellt sich auf einen
längeren Zeithorizont ein hat und man
sieht keine schnelle Lösung hat aber
schon naja Panik ist immer schlechte ist
man schlecht beraten in der Politik aber
das was in dem Land passiert was ich
jetzt gerade abzeichnet sie haben die
Banker erwähnt man muss mit jedem
Mittelstandsunternehmen sprechen in
allen Verbänden allen Industrieverbänden
Wirtschaftsverbänden in Sozialverbänden
es ist ja überall so ist die Angst vor
dem was auf uns zukommt groß und ich
glaube dass die Politik da sehr viel
getriebener werden wird als sie es jetzt
noch ist und was das dann bedeutet für
militärische Unterstützung vielleicht
gar nicht so sehr aber für eben diese
diese moralische Unterstützung dieser
Sanktionen wo es glaube ich noch ein
relativ großes zeigen Umfragen ja auch
Mehrheit gibt in der Bevölkerung das
aufrecht zu erhalten wird wenn man das
möchte politisch die Herausforderung
sein dieses Winters er kann wie wichtig
ist dass das sozusagen die Bevölkerung
ja damit geht und
etwas unterstützt all die politischen
Entscheidungen geben aus diesen Krieg
betrifft es gibt den zentrales Argument
der Bundesregierung was mir einleuchtet
da was etwa so lautet die Ukraine kämpft
nicht nur für sich sondern auch für uns
also dahinter steckt ja sozusagen das
Argument der Krieg vollzieht sich in der
Ukraine aber es geht um viel viel mehr
es geht um die Grundprinzipien der
raueratlantischen sicherheitsordnung und
damit hat der Bundeskanzler aus
nachvollziehbaren Gründen das was
natürlich aufgemacht wir sitzen alle mit
dem Boot es ist kein Krieg von
bestimmten Eliten und alle werden davon
betroffen sein und vielleicht haben wir
uns zu sagen der Illusion hingegeben das
ging es schon irgendwie so vorbei und
das wir würden hier schon so nicht
merken und ich glaube du hast gerade von
der Überraschung gesprochen das ist
glaube ich eine Überraschung die auch
die Politik zur Kenntnis nehmen musste
dass die Abkopplung von russischem Gras
von russischem Öl die Auswirkungen die
die Sanktionen auf uns selber haben doch
nicht so ab leicht abzufedern war mit
ein paar kleinen sozialpolitischen
Schräubchen wie vielleicht alle erhofft
haben wie kriegt man das hin die sind
Spagat zum einen natürlich eine Angst
eine Sorge die durch solche
Ankündigungen wie jetzt von Putin
natürlich wächst auf der anderen Seite
die Angst selber seine Energierechnung
nicht zu bezahlen also die Unruhen die
da befürchtet werden also wo wie loten
sie das aus in ihrer in ihren
politischen Entscheidung ich glaube dass
man auf der einen Seite genau das was
eben gerade gesagt worden ist sich
bewusst machen muss es ist einfach
möglich ein großer Krieg mitten in
Europa und Krieg der auf eine Art
geführt wird wie er der erste Weltkriege
macht den Aspekten der Zweite Weltkrieg
und dass das nicht spurlos sondern es
vorübergeht und wenn wir ehrlich sein
soll die Auswirkungen die die russischen
Maßnahmen an unseren Gesellschaften
haben zum Beispiel Finanzierung
rechtsradikaler in Italien in Frankreich
ziemlich sicher auch bei uns in weiteren
Staaten dass futin der Demokratie unter
Freiheit in der Ukraine direkt den Krieg
ein ganz Europa den hybridenkrieg
erklärt hat ich glaube das muss man sich
erstmal klar machen dass das zwar auf
der einen Seite für manche weit weg
erscheint und für auf der anderen Seite
ganz nah da und dann muss man sich um
die konkreten Auswirkungen kümmern und
das ist dann unglaublich viele Arbeit im
Detail wie zum Beispiel dass die
gasparche jetzt schon zu 90% voll sind
dass der strompreisdeckel möglichst
schnell kommt dass wir auch ein
gaspreisdeckel bekommen da wird man sehr
sehr viel Geld in die Hand nehmen müssen
und das ist dann wahnsinnig viel
Gesetzgebung im Detail auch dass wir die
erneuerbaren Energien schneller ausbauen
ich dauert natürlich alles genau
von 16 Jahren in acht Monaten wieder gut
machen aber einiges ist schon gelungen
nicht zum Beispiel ganz kurz zum Schluss
weil wir am Ende dieser Sendung sind
rechnen Sie damit dass jetzt oder Scholz
mitmacht mit dem was die Grünen fordern
eben doch mehr Kampfpanzer zu liefern
ich habe die große Hoffnung dass am Ende
die Bundesrepublik so ein Bündnis
schmiedet was man vorher gesprochen
haben nämlich wir haben ja bereits so
viel schon getan wir haben ja die
Ukraine schon ganz stark unterstützt es
ist ja nicht so wie es manchmal
dargestellt wird dass wir keine Waffen
liefern wir liefern auch sehr schwere
Waffen und da müssen wir einfach
weitergehen weil der Weg nämlich
erfolgreich war wie man zum Beispiel ein
Carglass sieht okay vielen dank
Hofreiter Frau Münstermann und Herren
für diese Diskussion vielen dank ihnen
fürs zuschauen das war die
frühlingsrunde heute zur Putins mobil
machen bis dann tschüss
[Musik]